no I feel like I felt moved on if you
thought Kim Kardashian and Taylor Swift
squash their be for good think again
these are things that may break out in a
full body sweat hours out to Taylor
Swift broke her silence about the
recently leaked and unedited footage of
her infamous call with Kanye West in
2016
Kim followed suit going off in a series
of tweets saying she felt left without a
choice but to respond and claiming
Taylor was lying yep the drama is alive
and well people but let's rewind a
monday taylor addressed the leaked
footage hitting up her insta story to
claim that when kim first released clips
from the illegally recorded call it had
been edited and manipulated to paint her
as a liar when the new audio leaked many
fans claimed it proved Taylor was right
in her ongoing drama with Kim and Kanye
but Kim says not so fast
the reality star tweeted quote to be
clear the only issue I ever had around
the situation was that Taylor lied
through her publicist who stated that
Kanye never called to ask for permission
nobody ever denied the word was used
without her permission I feel like me
and Taylor my steelhead Wow I made that
famous Kim continued claiming that when
Taylor and Kanye spoke the song was not
fully rigged adding the lie was never
about the word it was always whether
there was a call or not in the tone of
the conversation the camera crew filmed
him speaking to Taylor and got their
whole conversation I think she got
freaked out by the reaction and all of a
sudden she flips Kim also defended
Kanye's choice to film the call saying
that the footage never would have been
made public had Taylor not lied and
forced Kim to defend him just extremely
happy can you tell by my face and if you
thought it ended then think again
I'm not gonna stress about it Kim also
shot down the claims that she had edited
the footage to make Taylor look bad
saying she only posted a few clips to
her snapchat adding that the new footage
doesn't change the narrative I would
very much like to
excluded from this narrative while
Taylor's longtime publicist treat paying
caught wind of the beauty moguls Twitter
rant and clap back at Kim's claim that
she didn't edit the footage tweeting
quote I'm Taylor's publicist and this is
my unedited original statement by the
way when you take parts out
that's editing PS who did you guys to
piss off to leak that video Kim's sister
Chloe also responded to the exchange
writing I was about to take my ass to
sleep but then I just saw my sister post
a couple of tweets Kimberly you betta oh
good
Chloe and Kim's little sister Kendall
Jenner like all the tweets and Kim's
rant - also weighing in on the beep
Taylor's BFF todrick Hall he took his
instant story to slam Kim's response
hard calling her self-absorbed entitled
and stubborn among some other not so
nice dates don't be
[Music]
you